this week mall new peer reviewer
showed up in the headlines right this is
a merc
drug
that shows a
substantial capacity to fight
covid they report something like 50
percent
efficacy
um of malnu piravir now malnu pirovir is
not a new topic amongst those of us who
have been talking about the treatment
of
kovid in fact
uh i was having a discussion with pierre
corey about malnu pirovir
back channel back in june and july
right there's been a major investment in
this and merck is now trumpeting it as a
a great pharmaceutical intervention for
which it is seeking an emergency use
authorization i believe
but in any case um
pierre
uh
has a friend i'm not going to call him
by name he's a phd
uh
expert in infectious disease so he's
well qualified well positioned in the
world and what he says
i think will interest people in light of
what they may have read and heard about
malnouri peer review to support us like
this video subscribe to the channel and
consider writing a comment and because
1984 has captured 2021 click the link in
the description to see the full clip on
odyssey
[Music]
you